president biden will briefly transfer
power to vice president kamala harris
today as he'll be under anesthetic for
what's being described as a routine
colonoscopy the white house says the
procedure is part of the president's
annual medical checkup our correspondent
joe pike is live in washington for us so
acting president kamala harris then joe
exactly sarah that in itself is historic
the first time i believe that we've had
a female u.s president albeit very
briefly joe biden is due to head off
this morning u.s time to the walter reed
medical center about half an hour
outside washington probably a little bit
quicker if you're traveling as president
that is the same place
where president
trump stayed for a few days last year
when he attested positive for kovid 19.
now we know that joe biden is of course
the oldest man to serve as president he
is 78 he turns 79 tomorrow and just
before he became president his doctor
did tell us that he was fit to serve in
that role but was being treated for a
number of conditions non-valvular atrial
fibrillation high cholesterol
gastroesophageal reflux and seasonal
allergies this means as i say that
commonly harris his vice president will
be in charge the power be transferred to
her for a brief period and because of
that she will be working
from her office in the uh west wing
close to the center
of power at this
key time and the white house are very
keen to make it clear this is a process
set out in the constitution and this has
happened uh many times before they point
certainly to the presidency of george w
bush he underwent the same procedure in
2002 and in 2007.
it comes as at the same point as
president biden is trying to get a key
bit of legislation his build back better
bill through the house of
representatives this key social policy
and climate change a bit of legislation
which some argue is at the heart of his
presidency but of course he will not be
able to make calls to persuade
politicians lawmakers as they say here
to back it uh common harris maybe but
she'll probably have her eyes on a few
things as well as she will be serving as
president so he will be undergoing that
routine medical this morning including a
routine colonoscopy under anesthetic and
the white house sarah have told us we
will get a written summary from them as
to his medical condition later today